bonsoir madame Lacroix bon vous en
pensez
quoi de façon générale de cette nouvelle
approche pour la covid 19 donc fini la
recommandation de s'isoler pendant 5
jours
mais en fait c'est pas comme ça que moi
j'ai compris le message de la santé
publique en fait ce qu'on dit c'est que
si on a des symptômes que ce soit de la
fièvre de la toux des symptômes grippaux
qui peuvent être soit la covid soit
l'influenceurs soit le RSV on doit
s'isoler à la maison le temps que dure
le gros des symptômes et ce qui est
changé légèrement c'est la question de
la durée de l'isolement autrement dit si
les symptômes se résolvent très
rapidement on peut recommencer à vaquer
à nos
occupations mais en portant un masque et
en s'assurant de pas se retrouver dans
une situation où on propage le virus
donc il s'agit pas de dire que c'est
moins important de s'isoler quand on a
la fièvre des courbatures les myalgie
quand tous qui ont de la misère à
respirer au contraire cette
recommandation leur reste c'est la
question de la durée du 5 jours alors si
quelqu'un gardait des symptômes très ça
pourrait être plus que 5 jours
de la personne de se dire ok là j'ai
passé à travers la plus grosse période
donc je peux recommencer à travailler un
peu mais je me protège je me protège les
autres mais le docteur Boileau disait en
même temps si vous n'allez vraiment pas
bien vous restez à la maison vous vous
isolez donc ça veut dire aussi si on a
la covid après une ou deux journées de
symptômes on pourrait décider de sortir
et tout simplement finalement mais il y
a personne que jamais faite la police le
pour surveiller les gens s'il restait
vraiment cinq jours isolés à la maison
alors en ce sens là ça changera pas
grand chose l'important c'est de
conscientiser les gens pour qu'ils
sachent pourquoi ils font les choses et
puis qu'il les fasse correctement alors
si on voit des gens puis on en croise là
des gens qui nous tous en pleine face
dans le métro ou bien dans dans un
magasin c'est pas responsable alors on
essaie de conscientiser les gens que peu
importe le virus respiratoire qu'on a
que ce soit l'influenceur qui s'en vient
à grands pas le RSB qui est pas
tellement Bénin où la covid elle-même on
doit toujours prendre le même type de
précaution c'est sûr une approche
syndromasse on se base sur les symptômes
que l'on a pour décider ce que l'on va
faire et c'est ça qui est nouveau aussi
c'est qu'on vient d'élargir peu importe
le virus si vous ne vous sentez pas bien
vous restez à la maison et si après si
vous êtes quand même capable de faire
vos occupations vous portez un masque ce
soit la covid-19 ou un rhume ou
l'influenza exactement
qu'on retrouve dans la population
j'imagine mais si effectivement les gens
portent leur masse et respectent ce type
de consigne là d'ailleurs docteur
Boileau a bien dit qu'il recommandait
aux gens qui sont des maladies
chroniques qui sont des personnages et
des personnes immuno compromises de
recommencer à porter le masque dans les
lieux publics parce que la saison
automnale que va être assez féroce en
termes de virus respiratoire est-ce
qu'on va voir la combinaison des trois
cette fois oui c'est ça l'influença ça
va venir très très rapidement aussi
oui on s'attend une saison prématurée
parce que c'est ça qui a été expérimenté
dans les pays d'hémisphère sud et ils
ont eu une très grosse saison
d'influenceurs pourquoi parce que dans
les deux dernières années où on avait
des confinements puis des restrictions
que les gens étaient extrêmement
prudents mais on ne transmettait pas
aucun virus respiratoire alors il y a eu
un relâchement presque complet de ces
mesures là donc les virus respiratoires
se propagent comme ils le faisait
auparavant alors est-ce qu'on a appris
quelque chose la covid faudrait qu'on
aille appris quelque chose la covid
quand on a des symptômes on ne se mêle
pas aux autres pour pas leur donner
notre maladie peu importe finalement
est-ce que les tests sont encore utiles
dans les circonstances à votre avis
oui ils sont utiles ils sont très utiles
parce que si on ne la covid il y a des
traitements qu'on peut recevoir dans
certaines catégories d'âge dans
certaines conditions si on a des
maladies creuses chroniques il y a un
traitement que l'on peut avoir qui va
nous aider encore plus à éviter une
maladie grave et d'être hospitalisée et
c'est encore très important d'éviter les
hospitalisations notre système de santé
on ne présentements 1900 personnes
hospitalisées avec la covid c'est le
chiffre dont on n'avait pas lors de la
première vague on voulait jamais se
rendre à sauver nous on est rendu qu'on
a 1900 personnes on a 57 personnes aux
soins intensifs de la covid et puis
c'est comme si le système de santé était
capable d'absorber ça encore très
longtemps non alors si on a une grande
bague on sera pas capable de l'absorber
plus qu'on l'était lors de la première
ou de la cinquième vague
qui a changé et puis ça nous amène dans
les hôpitaux justement c'est que
appareil date l'an dernier on se
souvient que le gouvernement était
engagé dans une lutte contre les
employés de la santé qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés qui refusaient de le faire
maintenant nouvelle recommandations le
personnel le nouveau personnel n'est
plus tenu d'être vacciné contre la
covid-19 vous en dites quoi de cette
recommandation là je pense qu'on ne
manquer une bonne occasion de faire
quelque chose de bien le problème qui
s'est posé dans les hôpitaux c'est que
les gens étaient les rares personnes et
ils étaient pas nombreux à refuser la
vaccination avait déjà un contrat avec
l'hôpital dans lequel il n'était pas
indiqué nécessairement qu'il devait être
vacciné contre la covid parce que ça
n'existait pas mais faut se rappeler que
quand on travaille dans un hôpital on
doit être vacciné contre l'hépatite on
doit être vacciné contre la polio contre
nos vaccins habituels donc c'est pas
quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
demander la vaccination personnelle de
la santé et moi je pense qu'on se prive
d'un outil en disant on a demandé aux
nouveaux employés quand il commence à
travailler ben ça grosse partie du
contrat comme les autres vaccins qu'on
demande de recevoir que ce sera des fois
de recevoir le vaccin contre la covid
donc moi je ne partage pas la position
de la santé publique à ce niveau-là en
terminant docteur Tremblay qu'est-ce que
toutes ces nouvelles recommandations là
auront comme impact justement sur le
système hospitalier au Québec à votre
avis
si elles sont comprises par la
population dans dans le sens de il faut
augmenter notre vigilance par rapport à
l'ensemble des virus respiratoires et
donc on doit être d'autant plus prudent
quand on a des symptômes s'isoler le
temps qu'on a des symptômes portez notre
masque le plus souvent possible quand on
est dans des lieux publics ça devrait
nous aider à contrôler la situation si
c'est perçu que le message qui sort dans
les médias c'est que là le l'isolement
n'est plus obligatoire pour 5 jours il
travaille à santé ont plus besoin d'être
vaccinés c'est complètement l'opposé du
message que l'on veut envoyer on veut
envoyer un d'alarme peut parce que les
nouveaux variants arrivent plus
réplicatifs encore plus contagieux deux
autres virus en même temps nos urgences
vont être complètement débordées dans le
temps des facs sont encore plus
contagieux que ce qu'on avait oui tout à
fait le bq1.1 qui est le nouveau celui
qui émerge à travers les autres qui
doublent à chaque semaine en termes de
prendre la part du marché des virus il
est plus contagieux que le BA5 qu'on
avait alors vous vous imaginez et puis
il a tendance à échapper à notre système
immunitaire ça veut pas dire que nos
vaccins puis notre immunité naturelle ne
nous protège pas non ça nous protège
mais
plus le virus échappe à notre système
immunitaire ou à la protection est
solide et puis et puis ça ça met en
danger notre système de santé mais ça
pourrait donc se transmettre de plus en
plus au cours des prochaines semaines on
va voir docteur Cécile Tremblay
microbiologiste affectionnologue au CHUM
merci d'avoir été là ce soir
ça me fait plaisir au revoir si vous
avez